[Music]
let's go to bill in
central minnesota what's up bill
hey john how's it going i'm good my
brother how are you
uh nervous
hey listen have you ever listened to
this show
about every day okay you know i'm not
very good at this man you're fine you're
fine you will do a better job than me
i'm quite certain um but i appreciate
you calling man it makes my makes my day
that you that you trusted me on this one
so what's up
all right um
i don't know if it's a huge problem per
se or anything but my wife and
one of my exes
worked together
and
so i'll stop you right there and say yes
that's a big problem
so what is it not really what is it
uh they get along fine um it's not
there's nothing weird it's just um i
know how my wife kind of operates and
she constantly compares herself to
others and worries about what other
people think
and uh it just seems like she's always
kind of
worried about that or thinking about
that i'm kind of wondering what i could
do to
oh i don't know how to wear it i guess
um
how you can how you well let me let me
back up a little bit so when you say one
of your exes have you been married
before is this an old girlfriend no no
no just an old girlfriend is all about
okay
and it's just like a casual a lot of
weight into it like a casual fling old
girlfriend or y'all were pretty serious
oh yeah it was a few rules
do what
it was it lasted a few years okay so
it's pretty serious and how long have
you been married
uh we've only been we're very newly wed
been together about three years okay all
right so your wife has a year on
your old girlfriend in terms of
relationship time
how much longer have you known your
ex-girlfriend than your wife
uh
i guess we went to school together and
everything so quite a while okay
so i'll start right there that's
something that my wife brought up once
that i never ever thought of
which was so i'm friends with a lot of
my old exes like i i just liked being
friends with most people i don't see a
reason to
to
burn i just i just like people how about
that and um
it never occurred to me my wife said
some of these people have known you
since you were a small kid and i didn't
know you they will always have 5 or 10
or 15 relational years on you that she
could never catch up on and i used to
say yeah but we're married like you won
the game is over like there's not a game
anymore
and it never occurred to me that there
was
parts of my life that she would never
get to know that somebody else did
and so i i would start there with a
sense of
your wife is working with this woman
who has way more history with you than
she does
and that's not about looks that's not
about um
like did y'all hook up it's not nothing
like that it's just simply
that person's got more
history with my husband than i do and
that's just heavy right and so anytime
something like that gets called out uh
well before we do good on that road what
what does she compare herself to looks
uh smarts what is it
um
i kind of just
because my wife is amazing in every way
and i would never would change the thing
but she uh
it just she don't
she doesn't have the confidence so yeah
i'd say like looks and
um
just i think you you kind of hit home
right there with the time thing that
makes a lot of sense uh i can see that
when she brings up
their stuff and just they're uh friends
on social media but it i think it's just
so kind of keep your friends close to
your enemies closer type thing i don't
think it's
you know what i mean
yeah um so when you say looks does she
think that your ex is more attractive
than she is
uh i
feel like that's a dangerous one to
answer um no
i'm not asking you if that's the case
i'm asking does she think that does she
say that out loud
uh yeah she probably feels that way yeah
okay
um does she think that that other woman
is funnier than her or nicer than her or
cooks better or runs faster or is a
better leader i mean what what are the
things be very specific
um i think she thinks that i know
talking to the phone talking on the
phone man
i believe that my wife thinks that i
still have uh thoughts about my ex when
i don't and i have a hard time
convincing her of that okay just because
she's always in they're always seeing
each other you know they never get a
break or nothing there's always a
constant reminder of
my old life gotcha
okay so
here's here's an important thing to call
out
um
words and this in this
is this is a hard one to talk your way
through okay
this is one that you're gonna have to
live your way through
but i do think you start with words on
this one okay
and here's what i mean
have you all sat down and had a direct
not a passive not uh y'all are both
scrolling your phones but a
direct conversation about this
uh yeah a few over the years how how
have they gone not well or fine and then
she just loops back to the way it was
yeah the second one there correct
exactly okay have you ever told her in a
loving way not a mean way not a jerk way
but in a loving way
um
you were the woman i chose to spend the
rest of my life with to get old and die
with
i really don't want to talk about my ex
ever again
have you ever told her that
uh kind of actually i heard that on this
show before okay let's don't do kind of
let's sit down maybe write a letter to
your wife about how wonderful she is and
read it to her here's what i love about
you
i think you're beautiful
and i think you are hilarious and i
think you're really smart and i think
you're going to be a great mom for our
kids one day all
be very specific
and
often for guy it's hard like it's like
yeah just i love you you know i love you
and then i want you to be very specific
about
what are ways that i can
through my actions show you how much i
love you
and i know it's the hollywood sells us a
version that we're both to just read
each other's minds
and come up like oh uh she wants me to
do this this this and this around the
house and this and this and she wants me
to exercise
let's get real specific and what i want
you to do is to ask her put her on the
spot say i wanna um some things that i
can do
that will show you how much you mean to
me
and i'm going to ask you
one of the ways you can show me that you
love me
is i want to stop ever mentioning that
woman's name in this house
she's not who i picked i picked you
and
if your wife chooses to continually
compare herself to that woman
then at some point you'll have to decide
is that environment good for your
relationship
okay
and that would be hard that would be a
challenge
um but at some point the work
environment is not worth your marriage
but i want you you can't control that
that's her situation your wife's
choosing to do some of the comparative
things i want you to do all of the
things you can do in your power which is
just deal with your thoughts and with
your actions and so be very specific
with her about what how much you care
about and what you love and then be very
specific about asking for
what are some very specific things you
hear me say very specific over and over
again what are some things i can do
around here
that not to show you that i love you
more than her not to show you that i'm
over her
but that i can love you better how can i
do that i want you to be real
intentional and direct about that stuff
and this is gonna take two months five
months six months ten months and let's
go ahead and call out
i understand
clearly
that this woman knew me when i was in
middle school in high school there's
parts of me that she got to see that you
never got to see and let's just thank
god she got to see me with lots of zits
she got to see me with acting like an
idiot on the bus you get to see all that
and
i'm so glad that you didn't have to know
that that guy because
modern bill is way is a better human
being right so i'm glad but i also know
that's hard and um i i honor that that's
hard
but here's how much i love you now let's
start there and give that a shot